hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's 4 now I thought that I was
being super duper genius smart in the
last episode and I made a correlation
that there was you know when I looked at
the bad when there was no bears it
seemed like golden Freddy wanted to pop
out but you guys have informed me that
that's not correct
in fact golden Freddy or Fred bear is
the only animatronic available on night
5 I literally just have to listen for
him on what side he goes and then flash
closed door immediately so this is gonna
suck but as you all know I am the king a
five nights at Freddy's and I will not
give up my crown to anybody who wants to
impersonate a golden freddy or a
nightmare fredbear or whatever his name
is now I'm gonna beat him and I'm gonna
do it very quietly because I'm gonna
listen very closely for it who wants my
crown king of five nights at Freddy's
crown $0.99 marked down from five old
king sucks dong can't play game right
all right so apparently I'm not just
supposed to listen I'm supposed to
actively look which you know probably
probably a good idea I'm gonna do that
game on that sounded off like on the
right side yeah he's a stem stomping he
just stopped he womper he's just jumpy
wumpy Wampus woo boy he's a Stamper oh
no no [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah you better move on I sure wish I
had those two hours that would have been
nice
that would have been real cool to have
don't you [ __ ] dare you [ __ ] don't
you even think about it okay
all right cool so when he laughs does
that mean he's in my closet or something
well I do thinking about this logically
when he laughs that probably means
something special because I died right
after he laughed and he wasn't that one
of my doors would see them and he was
behind me or you know in the closet so
I'm gonna guess behind me cuz the closet
doesn't make a lot of sense how he would
get in there but actually no the closet
would only make sense because though
it's the only one I can close on him so
I'm gonna try the closet I'm gonna try
that with your stupid life oh come on
oh that's good stuff okay that wasn't
the laugh though [ __ ] where is he
maybe I am supposed to listen because
Alice that was messed up he was like bam
and bam and bam and bam she's going to
be [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you is he
zzzz by me huh [ __ ] you
it's going to be an ass blasting [ __ ]
Lloyd okay he laughed was that mean was
that mean is he in here
okay who's in there oh I see okay
laughed again does that mean he was
maybe no okay I'm [ __ ] okay okay that
makes sense that makes it so every time
he laughs not when he laughs when he
leaves but when he laughs he's in the
closet okay so long as I know closet
closet closet closet no what the [ __ ] I
don't want it I don't want it
what am i doing [ __ ] all day what the
[ __ ]
I was a coward house a coward I was a
coward I apologize for my cowardice that
crown still for sale it's been knocked
down to 45 cents anybody wants it oh
that wasn't a good sound that sounded
like inside that sounded like inside
crab crab crab crab crab crab crab crab
crab crab whoa [ __ ]
the [ __ ] we did oh good thing good thing
closing let's go let's go buy a gun okay
baby play me play me all right
okay he's definitely inside definitely
inside definitely inside definitely
behind definitely ours were there again
I saw him dammit what the [ __ ] does this
mean what the [ __ ] does that mean what
the [ __ ] does that mean what the [ __ ]
does this mean does this mean the [ __ ]
stop that
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] balls and [ __ ]
[Music]
I did I did it with skill and triumph
I'm dreaming dear I'll buy that crown
back for like a dollar haven't beaten me
yet it's my birthday oh crap that
doesn't look fun at all wow your brother
is kind of a baby isn't he
it's hilarious why don't we help him get
a closer look he would love it
no please come on guys let's give this
little man a lift he wants to get up
close and personal
no what the hell no I don't want to go
holy crap you heard the little man he
wants to get even closer hahaha hey guys
I think the little man said he wants to
give fredbear a big kiss on three one
two
was that the bite of 87
what
my whole world is turned upside down
that doesn't make any sense
so and let me look in the extras menu
then I'm gonna then I'm gonna see what's
going on here
connexes do we got here whoa that is
scary
okay so that was nightmare Freddy that
was nightmare bonnie nightmare chica
holy crap nightmare foxy ah that's where
okay I was wondering because everyone
was saying in the last episode the
golden freddy was nightmare fredbear i
don't know about you but still looks a
lot like golden freddy here Oh bless ya
be so cute and then question mark okay
making foxy whoa whoa whoa that's cool
that's really cool okay so there's a lot
of stuff to go on here making fredbear
jump scares fun with plushtrap and then
nightmare mode which should be really
interesting and there's a six-night so
obviously I'm gonna have another episode
after this and maybe another couple
levels episodes after that I don't know
how long the game is but this is weird
because I always thought that the bite
of 87 was because the animatronics were
possessed beforehand and I think a lot
of people thought that you know from the
original Freddy fazbear's restaurant but
this puts that in a different
perspective because this kid has been
having these nightmares and he's been
tortured by his family and especially
his brother and his brothers friends and
so he carried with him all these fears
and so when he was bitten by the
animatronic because there's his brother
and their friends shoved them into the
mouth of Fred of fredbear I guesses who
would be but golden Freddy I'm gonna
call him golden Freddy because it's
easier for me to remember but he was
putting the mouth of golden Freddy and
then he was bitten and then holy crap
and then like all his fears got
channeled in to golden Freddy or
whatever you want to call it you know
what I mean you know who I'm talking
about all his fears got channeled into
that and he was like the origin of all
these fears and why these animatronics
do what they do it's so weird but this
doesn't make sense still
because how did the murders happen and
where does the purple guy come into
place and where does all this go so I
think those questions are gonna be
answered either in the 6th night and the
probably the seventh night that's gonna
be including this so who knows who knows
who knows we'll know in a few episodes
here so thank you everybody so much for
watching click the annotation for more
Freddy stuff that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]